et maintenant voici mon stagiaire comme
villa
qui cherchait c'est toi qui a choisi ça
tu vas nous faire le coup de la
victimisation du stagiaire mais
évidemment voilà je suis le mal aimé je
le sais au sein de cette boîte
tu gagnes beaucoup d'argent pour ton âge
ouais mais je suis payé en France c'est
relou quand même c'est normal bon bref
la semaine dernière on a reçu Jacques
Attali qui compte peut-être se présenter
à la présidentielle de 2017 alors
beaucoup de gens sur Twitter ont été
très enthousiasmés par les propositions
qu'il a faites certains sont même prêts
à voter pour lui paraît-il j'ai la liste
comme Martine Nathalie Christian Dupont
Attali ou Jérôme Attali ça part très
très bien cette affaire
très beau plateau ce soir Thierry Lorie
Lorie l'idole des jeunes du début des
années 2000 on a vu nette sur Internet
comme Justin Bieber ou René la Taupe
alors Lorie attention on rigole pas
c'est 4 tournées 2 millions de
spectateurs ça veut dire ça fait près de
un français sur 25 alors si tu enlèves
les bébés les prisonniers les vieux et
les pédophiles ont pas le droit
d'approcher les enfants ça fait un
Français sur trois c'est énorme
c'est vrai Lorie maintenant faut vous
appeler Lorie pester alors
pour moi je vous rassure c'est pas pour
changer l'image c'est juste pour [ __ ]
les impôts
voilà les [ __ ] c'est une très belle
association qui donne des repas ceux qui
peuvent pas manger et puis un micro à
ceux qui peuvent pas chanter
non mais là vous faites votre retour au
théâtre pour la pièce Pygmalion
d'ailleurs il y a votre collaboratrice
Caroline qui a dit de vous à vous
surnomme le phénix je crois voilà c'est
vrai alors c'est pas méchant mais je
crois que ça colle beaucoup plus à
Jean-Pierre Chevènement quand même c'est
non mais ça va être Jean-Pierre
Chevènement c'est après Denver le
dernier dinosaure Jean-Pierre le dernier
des éléphants du PS parce que j'ai
demandé à Thierry pourquoi on vous
recevait il m'a expliqué que c'était
pour prouver à votre caserne que vous
étiez toujours parmi nous non alors
Jean-Pierre on est obligé d'en parler
parce que bah la fin est heureuse c'est
chouette voilà vous avez fait un coma de
8 jours en 98 vous rendez compte il a vu
la lumière blanche au bout du tunnel ou
alors c'était juste le médecin avec sa
lampe pour vérifier mais non mais
c'était peut-être la morphine c'est vrai
non mais Jean-Pierre c'est le seul qui
peut nous dire quand même c'est quoi le
plus dur vivre après un coma ou vivre
après un mandat de François Hollande
c'est incroyable
[Applaudissements]
Issa Doumbia
Issa comédien humoriste ou jouer dans la
série nos chers voisins sur TF1
en breton de 23 ans tout à fait je sais
pas ce qui était le plus dur de faire
croire que vous étiez étudiant ou breton
mais
il parait quand Jean-Marie Le Pen a vu
ça il en a fait tomber son œil de verre
mais mesdames messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser Lorie à l'âge de 5 ans où il y a
de Michael Jackson c'est à dire Willi
être noir et battue par votre père c'est
ça Doumbia
Issa dans TPMP vous avez déclaré enlever
Julien Lepers à question pour un
champion c'est comment lever Mickey à
Disney
c'est la place de Nabilla que vous avez
pris dans TPMP
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Pierre Chevènement tourné faire
garagiste
dernière question Jean-Pierre
Chevènement est-ce que pendant que vous
étiez dans le dans le coma vous souvenez
avoir été sollicité par gentil Berry
pour voter dans le 5e arrondissement ou
pas c'était bien possible merci voilà
c'était Tom villa et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de Inna larditube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu